makeup thing like there was a point
before i got sober i was on the the the
roast of gene simmons
i ended up getting kicked out of like
like because i like peed on danny
bennett bonnet dude didn't even make it
too did you make it out no i didn't even
i didn't even
they dragged me out before the [ __ ]
thing even actually started you peed on
danny bonaduce yeah i mean cannabis
was on the set that that was uh
dude i had all these great jokes [ __ ]
to tell on the roast and then i never
got to tell them but one of them
well let's hear them thanks man one of
them was uh i said
man i thought it was funny when
kiss
took off their makeup and went on tour
without makeup
but god damn it was [ __ ] hilarious
when they had to put it back on
you know like like uh
insinuating that that like someone had
said like guys like you look like [ __ ]
you need money
you're gonna appeal to a younger
audience perhaps you need to put the
[ __ ] right right
yeah there you go that was cool but you
know we come out like but i just felt
that that joke didn't land with you guys
maybe peeing on tiny bonaduce was a good
call
you didn't have to do that on a national
him i think i was peeing into a bottle
and kind of using him as a shield to try
to hide it before you guys were sitting
there there on some picture i'm just
sitting there you just walking danny
butter did she was in his legit roast
chair no is this he was it
was just uh recovering dana
is this
[ __ ] fifth of vodka
baby it's a good thing
trust me
i'm just chugging that boy
dude that was a burn
that was a good burn thank you yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's selling out
everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]
yeah dude